the Justice Department is considering
charges against WikiLeaks and its
founder Julian Assange tourney general
Jeff Sessions says his branch of the
government is ready to crack down on
those who share sensitive government
secrets WikiLeaks and Julian Assange
have been called a major threat Jeffrey
gazes in Washington now with the latest
on this story Jeff good morning good
morning the Attorney General said
yesterday that he is focused on
prosecuting leaks and the Justice
Department is taking steps to do that
official said are said to be
re-examining cases that were previously
investigated and they are targeting
WikiLeaks WikiLeaks and its founder
Julian Assange whenever our case can be
made we will seek to put some people in
jail federal prosecutors are assessing
whether to file charges related to the
release of stolen us information by the
anti-secrecy organization WikiLeaks we
are going to step up effort and already
are stepping up our efforts on all leaks
led by Julian Assange WikiLeaks has
published classified information
including nearly three-quarters of a
million sensitive documents from Chelsea
Manning in September of 2011 ahsan
shared his mission with 60 minutes if
you're a whistleblower and you have
material that is important we will
accept it we will defend you and we will
publish it last year the organization
came under fire for publishing thousands
of emails from the campaign of
democratic presidential nominee Hillary
Clinton WikiLeaks I love WikiLeaks the
Justice Department inquiry comes as the
CIA and the FBI are looking for an
insider either a CIA employee or
contractor who exposed top secret
government documents and hacking tools
sources familiar with the investigation
say it was someone who had physical
access to the material from his
Ecuadorian Embassy safe house in London
Assange said the 8,000 stolen CIA
documents were being passed around
before WikiLeaks published the trove
last month CIA director Mike Pompeo says
Asajj is a national security threat as
long as they make a splash they care
nothing about the lives they put at risk
or the damage they cause but it is still
relatively early in this process and
several officials tell CBS News the
charges against any one person or
WikiLeaks itself have not yet been
finalized Anthony Jeff leghe's thank you
Jeff